please welcome nacho and bobby flay
hi drew bobby i wish you were in the
studio with me
i know it looks so much fun there i mean
all those
all those puppies and kittens it's
amazing i mean i know you're
an animal lover and i can't wait to talk
about
nacho's new food line which by the way
um where's nacho he's right here
he's hanging out by his food you see him
gosh he really knows how to
pose and do it for the thing
so guess who i brought for nacho today
this is my rescue cat peach i think i've
sent you pictures of peach
specifically for nacho oh so cute
i kind of feel like they should date
she's single
peach all right well i mean i think
it could be it could be an online dating
success here what do you think
i'm i'm feeling it i've always thought
these two should get together
i like it nacho is the coolest
cat ever you have restaurants
named after nacho you have an amazing
food line that's coming out which by the
way i am
immediately stealing from the set you
know i get to feed
people every day of my life either
through my restaurants or
through my books my tv shows whatever
you know anasha is
clearly uh so incredibly important to me
and he basically whispered in my ear
like one of our during one of our
conversations he was like listen
you feed everybody else you know what
about us you know i have another cat
named stella who's his sister
and uh and it really got me thinking
that we should really you know together
with nachos inspiration
uh really come up with a cat food that
cats can really get behind
really truly a cat focused cat food so
you know using some of the things that
that i bring
to the table in terms of you know
feeding humans things like he's one of
his one of his secret ingredients is
bone broth
obviously using really amazing proteins
and ingredients so they have a very well
balanced diet
i mean that's really the key it was
something that we really thought about
and this is a family business it's
this is from scratch and it's just
launching this week and um
thank you so much for for talking about
it i'm so excited i'm gonna be
a loyal customer listen you're one of
the most famous chefs
in the world in fact you just got
a star on the hollywood walk of fame
yeah that was it that was an amazing
moment um
first chef to to get it on to get to get
a star
on the hollywood walk of fame and you
know that was that was that was an
amazing moment
very very very cool and it's so well
earned you really
changed the game
[Music]